if you want to change the world you must
be your very best in the darkest moments
you must know inside in the deepest part
of your being that you matter not just
that you matter but also why get a job
work hard save money pay taxes until you
question those hypnotic trances you
don't change want to be happy
build a life not just the business
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you to you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believed life and learn how you can
start to change the world
enjoy okay let's kick it off with real
number one know who you are with Oprah
Winfrey you must know inside in the
deepest part of your being that you
matter not just that you matter but also
why so for me the foundational base of
empowerment of entrepreneurship of any
kind of engagement the foundational base
of my success of my well-being my
wholeness my everything is knowing who I
am and where I come from in my living
room right now is a painting that I've
owned now for thirty years you can
google it it's called to the highest
bidder and it's at the center of my
house and it's at the center of my house
because it actually is symbolic of the
foundation of not the house but the
foundation for my life the painting is
by Harry Rosen who was a genre painter
painter in the early twentieth nineteen
century and the painting is over six
feet tall and it shows a slave woman on
the auction block holding her daughter's
hand and I cannot come in the door my
front door or I cannot leave without
passing that painting I am reminded of
where I come from every day of my life
and I am reminded because I never want
to forget it and in my library I have a
frame list of enslaved African American
people remember I showed you who were
held in bondage
on various plantations listed in the
Ledger's alongside the cows and the
horses and the buggies and the other
property and I passed this list every
day and often I stopped in front of it
and just speak their names out loud and
their ages Jonah's eleven years old
five hundred dollars Sarah forty-one
years old nine hundred dollars
Elizabeth fifty seven eight hundred
dollars and I forced myself to consider
the absurdity and the obscenity of
prices being affixed to each one should
they be placed up for sale and I
sometimes just pause before them with a
prayer particularly before I have to
make a big decision about one of my
companies or whether I booth forward or
whether I stay still it reminds me
speaking those names out loud not only
of where I've come from but how far I
have to go because of them and it
reminds me that I am never alone it
reminds me of what I've come through to
get through rule number two don't be
afraid of the dark with William McRaven
as navy seal is one of our jobs is to
conduct underwater attacks against enemy
shipping we practice this technique
extensively during training the ship
attack mission is where a pair of seal
divers is dropped off outside an enemy
harbor and then swims well over two
miles underwater using nothing but a
depth gauge and a compass to get to the
target during the entire swim even well
below the surface there is some light
that comes through it is comforting to
know that there is open water above you
but as you approach the ship which is
tied to appear the light begins to fade
the steel structure of the ship blocks
the moonlight it blocks the surrounding
street lamps it blocks
all ambient light to be successful in
your mission you have to swim under the
ship and find the keel the centerline
and the deepest part of the ship this is
your objective but the keel is also the
darkest part of the ship where you
cannot see your hand in front of your
face where the noise from the ship's
machinery is deafening and where it gets
to be easily disoriented and you can
fail every SEAL knows that under the
keel at that darkest moment of the
mission is a time when you need to be
calm when you must be calm when you must
be composed when all your tactical
skills your physical power and your
inner strength must be brought to bear
if you want to change the world you must
be your very best in the darkest moments
also if you want to have more confidence
motivation and self love check out my
250 part series they're free the link to
join on the description below I was
reminded this morning of a question I'm
often asked how do you eliminate fear
from your life look I have a I have an
unfair advantage you know I went to war
at war I'm alive because other guys died
for me whatever you're gonna call me
you're gonna call me whatever I'm gonna
be yeah I want a geek but whoever I am
you're gonna see me you're gonna see me
for who I am
rule number three question everything
with Robert Kiyosaki I think most of
your viewers out there sitting inside
their head or their words from their
mother and father go to school get a job
pay taxes save money buy a house cuz
it's an asset get out of debt yeah and
invest in the stock market that creates
poor people it's a hypnosis train going
through your brain so when people say
how do I change my life when you change
those words I wouldn't go to school
because you learn nothing about money in
school ask I wouldn't get a job because
if I have a job I'm an employee and then
I'd pay taxes and I don't pay tax
and I don't save money and I use debt to
get rich and I don't invest in the stock
market that's why I'm rich and so the
young people who are listening right now
they're saying but that's what my mom
and dad said but that's what mom and dad
say all over the world so to the young
people I just say challenge or question
what you've been taught because from the
Bible I'm not religious yeah the word
becomes flesh so if you say go to school
they said but I'll learn nothing about
money get a job you become an employee
yeah if you're an employee you work for
money I pay taxes then they tell you to
save money why would you save money when
the government's printing money you know
and get out of debt
well debt is money I use debt to get
rich most videos debt to get poor and
then fast in the stock market I don't
invest in the stock market
so when you when you wonder why so many
people struggle financially is they
haven't challenged the hypnosis the
words go to school get a job work hard
save money pay taxes until you question
those hypnotic trances you don't change
rule number four always do your best
with David Goggins do you like suffering
or do you just deal with suffering real
answer row answer yeah I like to see
real answer I like to get a bunch of men
together today men mm-hmm that are the
hardest of the hard mm-hmm and I want to
be with these men
and I want to see them suffer because
I'm suffering right along with you but I
want to see me get through it I want to
see what you're made of
I want to see like almost like the
Coliseum mm-hmm Iran yeah just going to
Coliseum and the only way to see who the
best areas is to suffer you can't do it
by writing a paper mm-hmm so let's go
because why would I found out through
my life was I thought of myself as some
weak little kid and when I found out in
the only message I'm gonna get across to
people is once you change one thing your
mindset you can attack everything and I
find it fascinating
I'm fascinated because I'll be in these
moments I put these guys on some
pedestal yeah which people do with you
they do with me and they shouldn't and I
was this guy who was a picture look at
these like that how are you guys it's
amazing but once I worked my way up
there that's it my god man we can all
compete let's go
so do I like suffering I like suffering
in the way that is competitive yeah that
brings out the absolute best in me and
in everybody else mm-hmm
so like I want to see a man be defeated
I want to see a man get broken and safe
you I love these men mm-hmm
these men I love but there's very few of
them mm-hmm there's very few of them and
there's very few that are willing to go
there more than once
I'm rule number five the last one before
a very special bonus clip is move into
action with Bob Proctor Don Shula they
coach of the old my Miami Dolphins he
said it's the start that stops most
people and he's right it is the start
that stops most people they're always
gonna get ready to get set to get going
what we've got to do is boom just like
that move into action see if you don't
get started you're never gonna get
finished how do we do that start early I
believe when you wake up you should get
up the second you wake up get your feet
hit the floor move into action and you
know you'd be wise if you sit down at
night before you go to bed and write
down six goal achieving activities
now that doesn't go to the store go to
the bank or get to cleaning it's not
that these are goal achieving activities
write down six of them and when you wake
up in the morning you move into action
you know where you're gonna go you don't
even have to think about it
step in actually get on the first one
when you get it done forget it and go to
the second one don't think about the
first one focus on two don't even think
about three when you get to then go to
three but not come off one at a time if
you don't get them all done just move
them over on to the next day and that
doesn't mean if you only get three done
that you have nine the next day there
are three of the six that you're going
to do the next day six goal achieving
activities and when you wake up in the
morning move into action on them
quit hold yourself back don't wait and
say well I really don't know how I'm
going to get started and the way will
show itself it just appears I have found
when you get started when you move into
action everything starts to happen
around you now I've got a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what's the dark that you are afraid of
number two how will you move into action
starting today and number three what
does always doing your best look like
for you and if you made it this far in
the video you're still watching and you
commit to taking action after watching
this video I want to celebrate you give
me a hashtag believed on the video as
well if you're not doing block time
here's what your day might look like you
have all these different slots of time
right and you're just gonna plug in as
you go through the day you're gonna plug
in
oh I'll work some there and work some
there and then I'll try to cram stuff up
right at the end of the day I'll try to
cram that sucker in any Crammers
Crammers Crammers femoris okay just
checking
no judgment no judgement you're just not
going as fast as you could that's all
Crammers there I love Crammers yeah just
like because they're easy to get to move
faster because you do have that
diligence of when there's a deadline and
it's on you can go which really serves
you but we gotta take you from a Crammer
to a prepare to a high performer and the
way that we do that is to look at this
and go listen if you keep leaving all
these time slots to randomness what
happens
is they start to get filled with the Big
D distraction some reason it seems like
this hit home for some people I don't
know why how do you recognize what I'm
talking about here so now you add up
take this out you might not be thinking
too serious about it but let's say
that's like a day 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
work hours you didn't know I drew that
on purpose
if you leave your time to randomness you
are stealing from your greatness
if you leave your time to randomness you
are stealing from your greatness bit by
bit
hour by hour day by day week by week
month by month quarter by quarter year
by year and decade by decade and it's
the little things like this where you're
like oh my gosh I didn't get anything
done because you've got all these random
approaches to your day
if you want to see what the best habits
and routines for success are check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
my sleep habits were horrendous to say
the least
and I've always had a hard time sleeping
there is one habit